I'm not doing it for no reason I'm doing
it so that the women that go through
something and don't have the balls to go
to the police they can actually say do
you know what at least there's somebody
there that says if I leave at least I'm
free of it nah because not everybody go
to the place if you can if you can't I
understand why you didn't and if you
want to message me then I will do AO
I'll help you don't worry my sisters I
got you because what you're going
through nobody knows until you're going
through it nobody trust me
um okay but I would also like to add a
slightly analytical perspective has any
of the viewers noticed that around these
conversations there's a there's a strong
pattern with feminists right so normally
it's everyone's being abused none of
them report it and their personal
experience counts for the reality so
it's normally like you know everyone I I
know two people who got jumped by by you
know guys on the street
um so that makes it a problem I didn't
tell anyone at the time but I was
suffering inside I was damages in all
these ways that no one can really prove
or evidence but I will tell you I was
damaged because I guess no one can prove
it
um and you know it's an issue for
everyone well that's why boys don't
report it so domestic abuse for boys
don't exist because the police don't see
it no what Alex is saying is that you
can't use the statistics when you're not
contributing to the statistics to defend
what you have not reported that's
basically what you can see I think you
can't use this you can't use that to
your advantage if you don't help
contribute that because you reporting it
no matter when it happens you can report
a year letter to your letters reported
help contribute to that statistic in
such a way it now shows and improves
their head you know because you know
even if they don't press charges today
or tomorrow or for your case like people
have patterns of behavior exactly and so
you're just contributing to the problem
by not reporting it like like by going
on a on a podcast using the story to
make you look good
and I don't need you to not make me feel
good and then not reporting it and then
saying that under the guise if I'm doing
this to help women it's like if you
wanted to help women then you would have
went to the police okay they're all
Noble victim it's like I don't know like
I think that sometimes when people like
talk about these situations they haven't
gone through they really get and don't
get the image for example the reason why
I don't even need to report it because a
lot of these things have happened in
public I never I I actually said
withdraw the charges I don't want him to
go to prison why because I love them and
I didn't want him to be in prison over
something that I thought me and him
could actually resolve family could be
involved in help but you're fighting a
law against against a lot of factors
that's why I say if you're going to use
the argument of Vlog or you're here
talking about it they didn't report it
didn't happen then men don't get abused
and it's the the point Still Remains
women get abused more than men that's
like as simple as that and that's why
I'm saying because men don't report it
don't happen no women one-sided abuse is
more common for women to do so if it's
if you're not if it's not mutual hitting
okay because like I I wouldn't say
that's an abusive relationship if you
guys are hitting each other like I would
I wouldn't say you're a victim you're
just toxic yeah it's just and so like I
would argue you're not a victim if
you're hitting each other constantly
this this reminds me of the theory of a
Hysteria
if you had like the victorians used to
talk about this this is this is like
you know quite controversial but the
victorians had this idea that um of the
hysteria that sometimes women would get
into history about things and like just
make stuff up and a lot of the time when
I talk to the feminists I mean outside I
do get the vibe that like she might be
because because there's people that they
all say the same thing it's like
apparently everyone's been abused
doesn't matter whether they go to top
you near the or the worst you need
everyone's abused especially when
there's a big median event all of a
sudden everyone comes out and they've
had the same story and I'm like really
like because because Amber Heard got
punched in the face now you were getting
whooped yesterday really I've known you
for like three years you know and I just
it just shows a lack of accountability
like when you ask them these questions
they start throwing out all these words
well it's because like it goes back to
if you really cared about women you'd
report it if you if you genuinely like
because you can report it you can report
it later and you might not win but at
least it goes on record and police can
pull up those records to use in a case
later cool like I said so any records
that need to be used will be used the
reason why I would prefer to use this
platform to speak about and to do that
is because like I said I don't only just
Champion women and men and sometimes man
today I meant to be on The Voice side
and I also championed the black
community culturally there's certain
things that I decided not to do because
I I have a complete a complex makeup so
I'd rather sit here and tell girls if
you're being abused and you don't know
what to do and you're lost and you feel
like your world is so lonely and nobody
can help you I'm telling you can get out
of it you don't if you don't feel like
we're reporting to the police don't go
speak to somebody somebody will
understand because people have gone
through and they've come out of it
stronger than whatever the situation
they were in so that's all I'm saying
abuse exists it's real is very very deep
and that's why people sometimes don't
talk about it the same way it goes for
men same way it goes for women but let's
not try and act like women don't
actually go through this and a lot of
the time like you said women will all
then say Oh yeah I was abused as well
yeah because a lot of people go through
things and they hide it they embarrassed
or they they feel ashamed or especially
when you're not talking about oh yeah
but you're damaged goods you know things
like that people won't speak up that's
what it is listen right you can go if
you're abused and you can report it and
nobody will know about it
nobody would know about it they've even
got special codes now that you can go
into a shop and you can say to them you
know give them a keyword I can't
remember what the name is it's a woman's
name yes
I need to call Angela well even in the
evening any shops or chemists or you
know I mean some pharmacies where is
that for men so it's not to say that oh
you're gonna feel shame listen right if
anybody's out there getting abused
Ripple it don't go and talk to your
friends about it Go and report it
there's nothing to be ashamed about
nobody needs to know don't go out there
and advertise it go and talk to somebody
about it that's what you need to do I am
Champion for the women it's nothing to
do with culture it's nothing to the
Blackness it's to do with women and men
full stop if you are getting abused go
and report it don't talk to your friends
about it as soon as it happens go and
report it because there is help for you
and I would like them to be codes for
men too and they should be coats for men
so that every man is getting abused
rather than going somewhere and you
think to yourself well I'm a man and I
have to go and report this they should
be a cold where a man goes into a police
station said the code and then he gets
treated the same way as if a woman says
the code I hear you antsy but um you get
some people out there
that they just won't go to the police
either because um they feel like the
priest ain't gonna do nothing about it
you know what I'm saying don't knock it
till you've tried it I hear you but um
this is I'm just saying in general
there's a lot of people you can't say
that to everyone if you've been abuse
gold reply to the police because not
everybody's gonna do that some people
don't even trust the police that some
people might have like oh maybe you say
for example oh yeah please killed my son
or you know I mean they don't trust the
police so everybody's not going to go to
the police I understand I understand
what you're saying but if they're not
going to report it and you don't want to
say nothing about it shut up about it
don't go on social media and advertise
it I agree shut up about it because I
don't understand how somebody could be
too scared too frightened to report it
to a police but they're not too scared
too frightened to go on a public
platform and talk about it it don't make
no sense it don't make no sense to me do
you know what it is right you get some
people right they feel like if they
announce you on the social media they
feel that they're releasing their stress
you know what I'm saying now that's from
my experience I've seen this you know
I'm saying in this generation right now
back in the days by indigenous right now
I've seen a lot of people when they're
going through this that they feel like
if they go on social media going to live
and then Express their feelings because
they just want the world to know what
they're going for yeah but there's
there's therapists I hear that but a lot
of people don't do that friends and
family like why are you going to on a
pot like if if you're saying you're
afraid if you're afraid of not being
believed if that's that's what you're
saying then you're gonna go talk to more
people about it that doesn't like two
plus two doesn't
yeah but like why do you I don't believe
it yeah I don't buy I I think it's a
form of social currency now have you
been abused
yeah oh how was it did you report it no
because then don't say you've been
abused then same as me sorry no that's
that's not how that works so so you
don't use your your experiences as a way
to kind of prove a point but that
doesn't mean you can't factually state
that like you ask the question so I'm
gonna answer your questions factually
anyway moving on
um yeah I think it's a form of social
currency I think because we've seen we
see this a lot right whether they'll
come up here and they've all you know
everyone's got their victims during
their Noble victims like I just feel
like they get a kick off it like it's
it's cool to be like
to be one of the downtrodden is cool to
be a victim sorry I wouldn't say it's
it's like
cool to be a victim
I went through it and I think maybe
because time has passed like you said
you you are now
you are now able to prevent about what
happened but maybe when you're going
through that and I'll say someone who
did go through that in two relationships
there was no way I could speak about it
because to me no one would believe me
to me I just had a baby with him and
you know you you've given this this guy
a son and it made your bed light and to
society especially to like Latin
American cultures Portuguese okay
uh you have to you have to like even
though as stupid as it sound okay you've
had a child with someone okay make it
look like you're doing well in life so
you don't want to come out and say you
know what I am being abused I am being
mentally uh being abused I have to say
mentally because it wasn't physical with
this one right
um so what happened a second time can I
so happened a second time uh the second
time was um it became physical
but with this one
it was both so I have to say that I was
also I got I also got physical with him
and there was a time that there was a
time the time I had bited him so hard in
the mouth and he had a bus lip for a
whole week did he call the police on you
no no he didn't because he he would
always say I'll never call the police on
you because that's not me I'm a man and
I'll take it and in my and in my head
Auntie Jenny I was like I'm I'm a piece
of [ __ ] because even though he's tall
and he's bigger than me I still hit him
and I have no right to do that so I am
abusing him even though he did that so
it was just like you say it was it was
it was an absolutely toxic relationship
but now when I look back at it I'm like
I I don't blame him I don't see him any
I don't see him any less because I was
just as bad as him like we were just as
we were just as bad as each other I
respect that you can admit that idea
yeah yeah I think it's definitely a lot
of um strength it takes to come and kind
of own up to your part in negative
experiences I've noticed a lot of people
who say these kind of things have this
idea that like they're never they never
had anything to do with it right I
couldn't have solved my own problem for
this that this that this that but they
can come out and and tell the whole
world about it but when you ask them
what did you do in the time I know
people who are like staunch feminists
and they're still dating guys and being
abused and telling me about like it's
some like Oh I'm a victim I was like oh
you've been reading all these like
Margaret Atwood book for time you still
didn't know when you were being punched
in the face that you should maybe leave
and you can't you can't like you can't
just be like all right I'll hold the L
you know I stayed in a bad situation too
long I should have moved but you rarely
get that it's normally everyone else's
fault so I respect I respect your
admittance thank you as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible